Boris Johnson Vladimir Putin thought
that this war would be over in days in a
week or so yeah did you fear the same
that was certainly the advice that we
were getting and the some of the defense
intelligence people were saying look
this is going to be very very one-sided
the Russians are just going to roll
through and uh numerically they're so
strong and they're so well so we're
equipped I'd been to Ukraine a few times
before and I kind of knew that they were
going to fight and if you you've been
there a lot and you talked to people
who've fought in the east in in donbass
since 2014. these are hardened hardened
Fighters so I thought it would be much
tougher than uh than than Putin thought
do you think that now they could be on
the verge of victory
I think it's absolutely inevitable that
the ukrainians will eventually win I'll
tell you why because this is a war of
independence and Wars of Independence
only really end one way and the crucial
thing for for us all who believe in this
cause who believe that the cause of
Ukrainian freedom is
all of our calls we just have to show
strategic patients and continue to
support them
beyond what does that Victory look like
there
I think the exact Contours of victory
are very much up to the ukrainians we
can't be more Ukrainian than the
ukrainians passionately though we may
support them it's up to them it's up to
Vladimir zielinski to decide I would
have thought that it's going to be very
difficult for anything to be acceptable
that stops short of a full return of all
the areas uh taken by the Russians since
uh February the 24th uh this year right
so could you see any solution that
allowed Putin to keep Crimea and and
all or most of the annexed areas
no frankly I think well I think Crimea
is a slightly separate issue and but
it's again it's for the ukrainians it's
not for us to to decide
do you think that Vladimir Putin is
running out of options
I think that
Putin disastrously miscalculated and a
we kind of in the UK government we all
read his crackers essay on Ukraine
summer of last year and we could see
that he fundamentally misunderstood what
Ukraine is it was like reading slobber
Dan milosevic on on the subject of of
Kosovo which I'm sure you remember well
uh slobo basically thought Kosovo was an
integral part of a greater Serbia and
the spiritual Homeland uh the origins of
uh of the Serb uh nation and I think
that's how Putin thought about kievan
Russ and and the origins of uh the
Orthodox faith and and all the rest of
it and it's a total category error
Ukraine is an in a free independent
European culture with its own identity
uh its own Ambitions its own destiny and
he made a fundamental mistake and so you
know he's he's but if he is running out
of fighting nationalism and but if he's
running out of options my point was
about him being cornered there's a lot
of talk about
tactical nuclear weapons do you think do
you think he would use them well first
of all let me just let's look at this
this your phrase and he's running out of
options and he has uh you know as a
limit to what he could he can do don't
forget Mark he's still overwhelmingly
supported by you know whether we believe
he's opinion puzzle well it's pretty
clear that he's supported by the vast
bulk of uh the Russian people
um yes there's a bit of kind of fraying
now in the in the media coverage and and
I'm not saying it'd be easy for him but
there is a world in which he can say to
the Russian people look we had a special
operation
we needed to denounceify Ukraine we
needed to make sure that uh it wasn't a
Haven for uh anti-russian feeling that
the Russian minorities were treated
properly and the Russian language was
protection we've achieved that
so I mean I think there is an option it
may sound crazy but I think there is an
option where he could and hold on to the
places he's taken like her son and that
will he will I don't think that's
credible for him anymore he will lose
those
his position is he will not want to lose
those and my question was do you fear
that he could use a tactical Nuclear I
don't I don't think he I don't think he
will I I think he'd be crazy to to do so
would it change the conflict if he did I
think what would happen is that
he would immediately tender Russia's
resignation from the club of civilized
Nations it would be a total disaster for
his country so the the current economic
punishment that the West has been able
to dish out would be
possibly intensified Russia would be put
into a kind of cryogenic economic freeze
and I think he would lose a lot of the
kind of Middle Ground of of global uh
tacit
acquiescence that he's had I mean if you
look at sub-Saharan Africa you look at
Latin America look at Lula for instance
uh who's just been elected again
look at South Asia
there's there's a lot of of willingness
to give Putin the benefit of the doubt
that will go the minute he does anything
uh like that he would also crucially I
think lose the patronage of the Chinese
and above all in his own country I think
he would trigger an absolutely
hysterical uh reaction so I don't think
that is a real what would be the West
Military response would there be a
military response there'd have to be a
military response I think the crucial
thing about uh strategic
nuclear deterrence and the logic of it
is you don't talk about what you uh
would do but clearly there would have to
be a a response of some kind uh but it
wouldn't have to be nuclear it could be
a it could be a very large conventional
response forces in Ukraine would that be
something that he should expect there
are all sorts of options that I know uh
you know we've talked about both in uh
in NATO and in the in the P3 the uh the
the Western nuclear powers of talk have
talked about uh there will clearly have
to be a response but as I say I don't
think it's going to I think it's very
very very very unlikely that it'll come
to that I I I think it's important
that we don't as it will waste too much
time on this conversation because this
is the this is exactly how Putin wants
to frame it he wants to frame it as a
standoff between a nuclear-armed Russia
and a nuclear-armed NATO that's what
that's that's how he wants to to present
it it's not so you know a brutal
Invasion it's about a brutal invasion of
an innocent country by conventional
means and what we are providing is the
conventional support that will enable
the ukrainians to win see I just wonder
how dangerous a moment you think this is
for the world
I think that this is a critical moment
for the world and I think it's a pivotal
moment it's a turning point and I think
the danger is that we will try to
compromise and uh find some sort of deal
some grubby bargain with uh with Putin
try to encourage the ukrainians to trade
some of their uh their territory which
will only encourage Putin to make
you know further further aggression as
we've seen since 2014 and but the prize
for holding firm and continuing to
support Ukraine is absolutely immense
because For the First Time in decades
we'll have shown that we really believe
in democracy and freedom and that we're
really willing to support it so I want
to talk those values in Europe I want to
talk to a Ukrainian Victory could be an
absolute turning point for the world
just a final point on the nuclear threat
how much time has prime minister did you
worry
about
the possibility that Vladimir Putin May
um use a nuclear weapon well for the
reason reasons Mark that I've given I
think it's very important that we don't
allow the whole debate to be framed in
those in those terms because that's what
you know he's like the fact that the fat
boy in Dickens he wants to make our
flesh creep right uh he wants he wants
to Spook everybody out with this
conversation uh I think it's far more
important that we concentrate on the
ways in which militarily uh
diplomatically economically we can
ensure that the ukrainians
see the Russians of right get them out
of their territory and and build an
independent future now Ukraine is
clearly personal to you it clearly means
a lot
um I just wonder why is that
I was very lucky I became a foreign
secretary in 2016 and one of the first
things I did was go to Ukraine and I
remember
talking to ukrainians who've been
fighting in in donbass and I remember
getting to see the this Great Wall uh
where they have I'm sure you you see it
many times yourself the the the pictures
of the thousands and thousands of
Ukrainian uh soldiers who've given their
lives for uh for the freedom and
Independence of their country
and I became very sympathetic to their
cause and I remember standing on on you
know on that beautiful Acropolis in uh
in Kiev and talking about uh the
possibility
that Russia might be so insane as to
take advantage of the fact that there
was no security guarantee to Ukraine
because Ukraine you know was not given
NATO membership and clearly it was a
problem because my point is and that is
that is what we now have to fix but my
point is that one minute you were
leading the world's response to Ukraine
in many ways the next minute
you know you were out of Downing Street
and out of power how did that feel
I think that thankfully the the UK has
got an absolutely seamless continuity of
of policy and uh Rishi I know had an
excellent talk the other night with uh
with Vladimir zielinski and we are going
to continue flat out to to support
Ukraine and and to make sure that we're
there and give them everything they need
now if I can make a plug for what I
think they need now I talked to a friend
in Kiev last night and
um as you know the the lights are out
there's no there's no water they're
having to queue for for bottled water
because they're getting these missile
attacks on their electricity facilities
and it's absolutely inhumane what the
Ukraine is now need we've given them
lots of great stuff from starting with
the anti-tank gun the anti-tank missiles
uh what they need is is more
anti-aircraft okay and ideally they need
fixed-wing aircraft to take to take out
the drones and the missiles but you
don't regret losing that influence and
losing that power because it in many
ways look it was your own mistakes you
made and that deprived you of the
influence and the power that you had
over Ukraine you must regret that
because that was something that was
clear I mean tempty as it is to that the
the most important thing is to uh Focus
not on you know me or my political
career well to focus on on what matters
all right let me put another one is
turfing out prime ministers the right
thing to be doing in the middle of a the
worst crisis the worst conflict since
the second world war in Europe I think
the important thing is for all of us uh
particularly in the United States to
remain focused on the needs of the
Ukrainian people and if I if I may say
so the UK you're kind of what you said
about the the role of the UK and I think
it's true we did play an important part
uh particularly at the beginning but
actually throughout in in bringing our
friends together in organizing those
great
um uh yeah you know what businesses
I want to talk about the commitment let
me just say this initial thing is it is
in North America and I want to come on
yes our American friends are making I
want to do that just finally on this
zelenski was your friend he is your
friend very fond of you they're even
naming a street after you in a sense
didn't you let them down by by the
mistakes that led to you leaving office
I see what you mean look uh I certainly
uh want to do everything I can to help
Ukraine and that's always been
um you know my my commitment I've said
that to uh to Vladimir irrespective of
whether I'm in in office I think there
are ways I can be I can I can be useful
um
for instance how would you be I think
it's very important that the
um
America has been extraordinary Joe Biden
has been absolutely wonderful and you
know people may not expect me to say
that but I I think he he
America as so often massively surprised
on the upside I mean 44 45 billion
dollars tone half million dollars worth
of uh military equipment the the high
Mars the uh the the rocket systems to
take out uh Ukrainian uh you've got the
Republicans couldn't take out Russian
Munitions Republicans who win the
midterm elections take over Congress and
they are saying there is no blank check
for Ukraine correct that's what I I
thought that's what uh my old friend
Kevin McCarthy uh said the other day and
I I you know I think that actually when
you talk to individual Republicans they
see the the vital importance of this of
this struggle uh but yeah if I can be
useful in trying to get over to people
why I see this as such an absolutely
critical test of of Western will uh then
I think that'd be a good thing to do but
it's it's America that is is crucial
America has given so much of the uh
Military Support so much of the economic
support but do you worry that that may
now Wane I think people you've always
got to be
you know it's a lot to ask of any
country particularly in tough Economic
Times and the Americans have been
fantastic I mean the UK has given a huge
amount as well we'll be given a huge
amount of money huge amount of military
assistance but do you see any future
British government going soft on Ukraine
even even you know on the persuading
zielinski towards negotiations or
persuading him to do a deal I I would
argue
passionately against that and just for
this reason that I don't think and I
don't think it's likely to happen but I
I just don't think it's realistic
because there's no deal that zielinski
can do and there's no deal that Putin is
offering there were reports that Rishi
sunak was trying to limit the amount of
money that you were
um giving to Ukraine and the amount of
support that you were giving to Ukraine
is that true I think the the the UK
support has been uh I was going to say a
second to not between second to the
Americans otherwise it's been it's been
it's been so he never tried to uh we've
had we've had we've given uh a huge
amount of financial support and I think
the decisive thing that we did was to to
read it early and read it right and to
help them with particularly with the the
end laws the anti-tank weapons in the in
the early days those were very but given
the
um constraints that there may now be on
government spending do you fear a
curtailment a limiting of the resources
going to Ukraine my no I think that the
uh well obviously there's a there's a
practical limit on on what we can give
both in Munitions and and financial
support but we will continue to I've
absolutely no doubt uh the conservative
government will continue to be very
supportive and very generous because
this is this is should they commit to
the streets this is pivotal for our our
future do you think they should commit
to the three percent of gdpi on defense
spending by 2030 I think it is I think I
think I pointed out that under uh under
our current commitments were good I
think we're already at 2.4 uh we're
going to go to 2.5
uh uh just you know we continue with uh
with orcas and uh and fcas and the
future combat aircraft system and
various other things we're going to
spend a huge amount on defense what
about whatever happens what about the
commitment to the British public a poll
We Have Tonight suggests people are
committed to support Ukraine but that
support weakens significantly if it
means higher energy bills what would you
say to the British public I think I I
really understand people's uh
pain or anxiety about energy prices and
the the misery of what everybody's been
been going through but I would just say
to people that this is a chance for us
in the UK actually in the whole of the
the Western World to get through get off
our dependence on Russian hydrocarbons
and build a more secure future for
ourselves in which we rely on our own uh
domestic production of renewable energy
or indeed nuclear energy and and have a
totally different future so the truth is
and this is why I'm very optimistic
about what's happening I think that
actually with every week and every month
that goes by we become more resilient
more capable of providing for our energy
needs and less dependent in the future
on on Vladimir Putin um how worried are
you that Russia hacked the personal
mobile of your foreign secretary
um and quite possibly got details of
dealings with Ukraine you know we never
talk about uh security issues
but I mean that must be a worrying thing
that it happened in your
government we never talk about security
issues as you know is that why it was
surprised you didn't say anything about
it at the time it wasn't it but Mark was
it to protect um what's called potitio
principia you'll bet you're asking me to
uh to discuss something which I've said
I won't discuss and that we don't we
don't talk about security okay so
finally you would like to stay involved
with Ukraine what kind of have you
spoken to Rishi suneck about a role a
possible role yeah I think what I can do
and what I will want to do is to
continue to to Champion the cause of
Ukrainian freedom of a free Sovereign
independent Ukraine it is a great cause
I think it's a cause that has mobilized
a phenomenal level of support across the
UK would you like a formal role I mean
do you see it I'm happy with doing the
kind of envoy role I think you know this
is this is my job is to to talk up what
I think are the immediate needs of the
Ukraine is if I can just repeat that
that key point for our our viewers I
think what I'm sure you'll you're
brilliant correspondence you've done by
the way are fantastic job throughout
this uh throughout this this War I think
what they would what they would agree
with they need more help in in taking
out those those drones and those
missiles will you go back to Ukraine
inevitably but I'm not saying I'll let
you know before I go but yeah last two
um do you feel more appreciated on the
world stage than you do domestically and
is that is that one of the reasons
you're going to go to cop27
um I have a
absolutely passionate belief that uh the
war in Ukraine Putin's Act of aggression
is something that we shouldn't accept
and shouldn't tolerate
um I I think that I can continue to
campaign for Ukraine out of office and
that's what I'm gonna do are you going
to go to cop 27
yes as it happens but um that's
that's not relevant to Ukraine and final
question I mean do you still Harbor
Hotel I was invited by his invited by
the by the Egyptians and you presumably
think the Prime Minister should go I
think the the premise is doing uh as as
he's pointed out he's got a massive
amount to do we've got to sort out uh a
huge
agenda that's what he's getting on with
um I happen to have a particular I was
at the the Glasgow cop although it's
become unfashionable to talk about it
was a fantastic Global success we did a
huge amount of good for the planet I
want to talk a little bit about uh how
uh I see things and how we see things in
the UK and do you still Harbor hopes of
returning as prime minister is it
unfinished business
Mark you promised this was going to be
about Ukraine I I Harbor hopes of
continued campaign for uh for Ukraine
and that is my priority and there are
various other things I'm doing but that
is of course it's very dear to my heart
Boris Johnson thanks very much thank you